you've been doing this show disjointed
where you play the owner of a marijuana
dispensary and that is a story that's
all over the news it's I think record
recreational marijuana was legalized in
LA and it's starting up like today I
mean this is incredible the the
synchronicity with you guys only
starting today that it's legal I don't
know I think it was Ben Lee oh okay I
thought it was January first oh you've
been breaking the law
oh god you just tried pot the first time
on January 1st Wow incredible do you do
you I mean first of all your show tries
to depict it's a comedy but they're
really you're really trying to depict
yeah we're we accurately yes because we
actually that one of the cool things
since I really didn't know a lot and I'm
still learning about marijuana yeah we
don't like to call it dope right you
know no one calls it dope any not since
like that you were caught up calling it
that a lot just now dope yeah didn't you
call it dope no are you high now what's
going on like I said toe okay call it I
call them those funny cigarette
cigarettes
no okay where are we oh my god okay all
right no I'm really really I'm not I
don't do that yeah yeah yes what were
you doing backstage wait a minute we we
have a cannabis consultant you have a
cannabis yeah she's actually her name is
dr. Dina and she's one of the four
dispensaries medical she was medical for
15 years in West Hollywood and they were
one of the first four to get licensed
right you know in January first and she
said it was just like there was a line
around the block yeah you know and after
the weekend it was like it was like the
this the shelves were decimated yeah you
know there was no inaudible who knew
people like this stuff it's incredible
and a lot of first-time users they want
to be educated right well what's amazing
is so you have a you have a cannabis
consultant to help you sort of add
realism to the show right right sort of
teach you how it all
how it all works right you you've had
some familiarity with with pot in your
and your regular life yeah well I had
cancer twice right and so I I found that
I couldn't I couldn't really do the
opioids you know the oxycodone really
made me sick and other stuff and so I've
learned that the marijuana takes the
nausea away and you know there's a lot
of other good things the anxiety you can
you know the cool thing about it now is
that they have different deliveries they
got they've got like vape pens and stuff
so that you don't have to get whacked
you know right right
yeah but you can keep it in second do
you want to go into fit right yeah I
mean who wants to get high on this stuff
anyway no nobody I would think it'd be
very good so you use that and people who
have gone through cancer treatments and
and various ailments just you know pain
pain management they swear by and the
NFL a lot of the NFL stars are using
marijuana to treat their early onset
dementia right and no really there's a
group called the grid there's really
there's a group called the gridiron
cannabis collective and they came on our
show and they did a commercial there
there's someone on my staff who has you
know smokes her fair share of pot and I
was asking her why and she was like from
my anxiety
she has
you